China is being accused of censoring
critical data about the coronavirus
which the World Health Organization now
calls a grave threat to the world
according to scientists writing for The
Lancet medical journal Chinese
authorities had preliminary information
on the virus for more than two weeks
before it was officially released one
citizen journalist documenting the
outbreak in Wuhan that's the city at the
center of the outbreak has reportedly
been arrested another has just
disappeared Debora patta is in Hong Kong
with more on this story Deborah what are
we learning good-morning hashtags
bearing the names of those two
journalists are trending online right
now and with the number of infections
and deaths soaring scientists are
worried that a lack of transparency
could deepen this crisis everyone wants
to know what's going on I mean I don't
want to panic but it could become a
global pandemic in the two months since
the world was exposed to the existence
of the corona virus there are still
questions about just how severe the
crisis is and whether China has been
fully open with the global community
have they been transparent we're finding
out things in bits and pieces they were
not transparent at all I would say
during the month of December as we know
there was a doctor trying to raise the
alarm that doctor was Chinese national
Li wen Liang he was silenced by
officials after issuing an early warning
about the virus and died from its
disease last week two citizen
journalists who documented hospitals
overwhelmed by the epidemic and the
shortage of resources and doctors in
Wuhan have disappeared or been arrested
it's very typical Chinese government to
try to control the narrative of this
thing they don't like scenes of people
lined up on the floor of a hospital not
able to get a bed and that feeds into
this whole idea that we have no idea how
bad this epidemic is right now so can we
trust the information that's coming on
no we can not every place in every
province in every village in every town
contest for the virus the number of
infections is surging the World Health
Organization is meeting for a second day
to try and get a grip on the virus do
you think that because there's so much
global pressure this
sort of blow things open a little bit in
China it's awfully hard to keep a lid on
things like this for a while the global
community wants to know the World Health
Organization wants to know this is no
longer just a problem of China it's a
problem for the world according to the
nonprofit organization Chinese human
rights defenders more than 350 Chinese
citizens have been either detained or
fined for simply discussing the epidemic
online attorney
all right Debora patta forests in Hong
Kong Deborah thank you very much